maurice lemoine journaliste spécialiste
de l'amérique latine ancien rédacteur en
chef notamment du monde diplomatique
bonjour maurice lemoine merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct sur
arte france que les sanctions
européennes ne vont pas affecter l'aide
médicale apportée par l'europe au
venezuela
ça a été donc confirmée par plusieurs
pays membres de l'ue
comment est-ce que les sanctions vont
être se traduire sur le terrain moi
c'est une décision mais c'est une
déclaration parfaitement hypocrite en
réalité je veux dire en en appuyant les
mesures coercitives unilatérales
imposées par les états unis au venezuela
l'union européenne seront se rend
complice d'un creusement ce qu'on peut
appeler une véritable crime dans la
mesure où je le rappelle quand même les
fondamentaux la haute commissaire de
l'organisation des nations unies aux
droits de l'homme mme michelle bachelet
a demandé le 24 mars que les sanctions
internationales qui frappent le
venezuela mais aussi couloir éliront
soit assouplie ou suspendus vous avez le
secrétaire général de l'onu antonio
gonzalez qui a présenté un rapport
exigeant la levée et la suspension des
sanctions est en réalité lorsque l'union
européenne tente de se dédouaner
elle se rend bien compte qu'elle est
dans une politique est une politique
absolument scandaleuse et ça fait
référence à une décision du conseil
européen du 25 juin 2018 qui a adopté la
décision sanctionnant des membres de
l'administration vénézuélienne dont ceux
opérant dans le secteur de
l'alimentation dans le secteur de
l'alimentation
et cette mesure elle fait elle fait écho
à celle qui avait été prise
là non plus tôt qu'en gros parle par les
états unis afin de rendre impossible ou
en tout cas difficile l'achat d'aliments
par le gouvernement vénézuélien pour
parler beaucoup des états unis on sait
que washington le 1er avril
avait annoncé des mesures restrictives
contre caracas dans le cadre d'une vaste
opération anti drogue qui aurait cas
soutenu par moscou avait dénoncé cette
décision peu après dans une lettre aux
nations unies quelles peuvent être les
conséquences sur quoi est ce que ça peut
déboucher tout ça non là les
conséquences et de mettre ce pays le
venezuela comme d'autres d'ailleurs
soumis à des à des sanctions je pense en
particulier à cuba dans la région dans
une situation extrêmement extrêmement
difficile dans la mesure où tout ceci a
pour seul objectif de renverser le
président ma tour lorsque l'union
européenne l'a récemment encore le 4
avril donc il ya quelques jours a
soutenu un pseudo plan américain pour un
gouvernement de transition au venezuela
c'est le jeu josette borel le chef de la
diplomatie européenne qui ça qu'il l'a
déclaré on se rend bien compte qu'il
s'agit avant tout d'une tentative de
renversement de nicolás maduro
effectivement ces sanctions elles ont
des répercussions en europe âge peut
malheureusement nous n'avons pas le
temps vous faire la liste des dd de
commandes est en hausse de 4 et précis
l'une des premières banques à la
commerzbank allemagne qui a charmé les
comptes de plusieurs institutions
vénézuélienne vous avez euroclear à
bruxelles qui retient un milliard 400
millions de dollars du gouvernement
vénézuélien
vous avez là lalbenque onovo portugal
qui retient deux milliards de dollars du
venezuela
donc on est dans une situation de
pandémie il faut rappeler en face d'une
opération qui est une opération purement
criminel mais il n'y aurait aucun impact
sur l'aide humanitaire
médical destiné au pays comment est-ce
qu'il faut accueillir du coup cette
déclaration malgré les sanctions
mais il n'y a aucune aide humanitaire de
l'union européenne ou d'auteuil l'union
européenne en direction du venezuela le
venezuela est aidé par la chine par la
russie par cuba c'est à dire par hasard
dans nombre de pays indépendant et qui
ne se considèrent pas comme devant obéir
aux diktats et des états unis
mais pour autant évidemment ça va ça ça
ça complexifie beaucoup les choses
lorsque vous êtes obligés d'aller
acheter des médicaments en inde par
exemple ça serait beaucoup plus simple
d'acheter mais y compris aux états unis
donc les répercussions elles sont elles
sont permanentes pour ce pour ce pays
et est ce qu'on peut trouver des
solutions qu est ce qui peut être
envisageable justement pour atténuer
tout toutes ces tensions
non mais je veux dire il ya ne serait
envisageable que le fait que l'union
européenne suive fait plutôt de suivre
les états unis pour imposer un des
sanctions économiques un blocus
financier au venezuela et à dire que
l'union européenne devienne un tout
petit peu indépendante pour ses
décisions politiques
les sanctions contre le venezuela sont
déjà scandaleuse en temps normal mais en
temps de pandémie on est là face à un
cas qui restera dans l'histoire comme
non assistance à un peuple en danger
dernière question rapidement ouest
moyneur que pensent les les vénézuéliens
de tout cela en pleine pandémie
écoutez tous les tous les vénézuéliens
qui soit de position ou qu'ils soient
pro maduro d'abord un sont confrontés à
cette situation de pandémie et 2 et 2
chacun d'entre eux souhaiteraient
pouvoir bénéficier des soins et d'une
aide internationale la plus large
les internationales elles existent à
travers l'organisation mondiale de la
santé à travers l'unicef à travers un
certain nombre d'organismes indépendants
mais il est évident que ce blocus des
pays européens et des états unis qui
sont finalement des pays importants
complexifie singulièrement la situation
seulement de la fin merci nous reste le
moins d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste de l'art chrétienne et
notamment au cirad et en chef du monde
diplomatique